listen  it has begun  [Music]  it is time marvel studios are turn-offs  pg-13 get tickets now  oh my god i have so many does it have to  be three  heart emoji shades emoji and then the  strong arm one the old lady emoji the  shushing emoji and the robot emoji  smiley face with a little sweat drop at  the side eyes rolled up emoji the  flowers emoji i'm sure that was a lot of  fun for you it was  [Music]  beer emoji the sleeping emoji the kind  of grimacing emoji you know what's never  saved the planet you're sarcasm only  three emojis i could do 20 emojis heart  biceps first emojis  irish flag emoji shamrock emoji wolf  emoji  there is one that is kind of like a  ball of fire a horse  and  a volcano  it is time marvel studios eternals is in  theaters november 5th book your tickets  today  you